>>> WELCOME BACK.
A NEW DETAIL TODAY ON WHO IS
SPEAKING TO THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN, CONGRESSMAN BENNIE
THOMPSON, IT'S ONE OF TRUMP'S
BIGGEST DEFENDERS, FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR.
>> TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL ALREADY.
WE HAD TALKED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE INDIVIDUALS.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT OUR
MILITARY WAS PART OF THIS BIG
LIE ON PROMOTING THAT THE
ELECTION WAS FALSE.
SO IF YOU ARE USING THE MILITARY
TO POTENTIALLY SEIZE VOTING
MACHINES, EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
DISCUSSION, THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO
KNOW.
>> JOINING ME RIGHT NOW, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR MICHAEL
ZELDEN AND HOST OF THE PODCAST
"THAT SAID" WITH MICHAEL ZELDEN.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU, MICHAEL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT THE
CONGRESSMAN IS SAYING PUBLICLY
THAT BARR HAS ACTUALLY SPOKEN
TO -- IS SPEAKING TO THE
COMMITTEE?
>> WELL, IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
SURPRISE ME THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR WOULD BE SPEAKING
TO THE COMMITTEE.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT THE BARR BEING THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER AND IN HIS
POCKET AND ALL THAT STUFF.
BUT BARR HAS A STRONG
CONSERVATIVE VEIN IN HIM, AND I
THINK THE USE OF THE MILITARY IN
A DOMESTIC MATTER PROBABLY IN
VIOLATION OF THE POSSE COMATATUS
ACT WHICH PROHIBITS THE MILITARY
FROM BEING USED IN THIS
CAPACITY.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD BE
UNHAPPY TO TALK TO THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT THAT.
>> SO YOU JUST HELPED ESTABLISH
THAT AS LAWFUL.
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW TO TRY AND
USE THE U.S. MILITARY FOR
CIVILIAN TO ENFORCE A CIVILIAN
KIND OF POLICY OR USE THEM AS
CIVILIAN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO IF THAT'S THE CASE, AND THERE
ARE EYEWITNESSES AND YOU HAVE
THIS DRAFT EXECUTIVE ORDER, WHAT
MORE EVIDENCE IS NEEDED?
>> WELL, WHAT WAS THE PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT THE ORDER IS WHAT'S
UNKNOWN.
WHO, BESIDES SIDNEY POWELL AND
MICHAEL FLYNN ARE BEHIND THIS?
WHO IN THE MILITARY, IF ANYBODY,
WAS WILLING TO EXECUTE THIS
ORDER?
SO WE NEED TO KNOW AT A VERY
GRANULAR LEVEL WHO WAS INVOLVED,
WHAT IT INVOLVED AND HOW IT WAS
GOING TO BE DEEMED LAWFUL BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OR THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE BEFORE
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS SIGNED.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF UNKNOWNS.
>> IS IT YOUR FEELING THAT OF
THOSE 700-PLUS PAGES, THOSE
DOCUMENTS RELEASED BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES THAT THE
ANSWERS ARE IN THAT IN TERMS OF
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN A PARTY TO
CONSPIRING TO USE THE U.S.
MILITARY IN THIS SENSE?
>> WELL, WE'LL HAVE NAMES.
WE'LL KNOW NAMES LIKE GIULIANI
AND MICHAEL FLYNN AND SIDNEY
POWELL, BUT WE WON'T KNOW WHAT
WERE THEY SAYING.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THESE
SUBPOENAS.
THE COMMITTEE HAS THESE
SUBPOENAS OUT TO ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE TO SAY, FINE, WE SEE YOUR
NAMES CONNECTED WITH THIS
DOCUMENT AND WE WANT TO KNOW WHO
WAS SPEAKING TO WHOM ABOUT IT.
WHAT WAS SAID?
WHAT WAS YOUR PLAN?
SO THEY KNOW CONTACT BUT THEY
DON'T KNOW CONTEXT YET.
>> CAN YOU GIVE US THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN HOW
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
SPEAK WITH PEOPLE VERSUS
ACTUALLY SUBPOENAING THEM?
>> RIGHT.
WELL, YOU CAN GET A PERSON'S
TESTIMONY VOLUNTARILY OR BY
SUBPOENA.
IF THEY REFUSE TO VOLUNTARILY
COOPERATE, THEN SUBPOENA IS THE
NEXT ROUTE.
THESE FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE VERY
RELUCTANT WITNESSES.
THEY'LL ASSERT ALL SORTS OF
PRIVILEGES, MOST OF WHICH
PROBABLY ARE NOT AVAILING, BUT
TO DELAY THE PROCESS.
SO I THINK IN CASES LIKE THIS,
AND REALLY IN MOST COMPLEX
FINANCIAL CRIMES IN FEDERAL
CASES YOU HAVE DOCUMENTS BUT YOU
REALLY NEED INDIVIDUAL LIVE
TESTIMONY TO ILLUMINATE WHAT
THOSE PAPER DOCUMENTS SAY.
SO I THINK THEY NEED THIS
TESTIMONY, AND THEY SHOULD GET
IT AND IF THEY CAN'T GET IT,
THEY SHOULD MOVE FOR CONTEMPT
AGAINST THES